first of all what stands out to you here
I mean the sheer size as well as the
fact that it took two years to figure
out that this happened what do you think
is most significant yeah so the size is
immense right I mean this is the largest
number of records stolen in any breach
in the history of well the internet if
presumably the the other big thing that
stands out is you know we say that it
took two years to for them to figure it
out or to find it that's true but it's
this that when you have a
state-sponsored attack like this one
thing they're really good at is hiding
their tracks right when you have an
individual who's trying to attack a
company they have one main goal which is
to steal as much as they can presumably
build dossiers of the individuals found
in it and then sell that as quickly as
possible right because they want to
fence it whereas when you have a
state-sponsored attack presumably their
motives are not to make a quick buck
their motives are you know more sinister
or at least deeper than that and so
they're very very good at hiding their
tracks and persisting within the network
it's it's it's hard to find this out
until such a point that you you
accidentally stumble upon it basically
because again they've hidden their
tracks so well and so I think the fact
that they found it now is a good thing
whether or not the state-sponsored
attacker is still in the network i think
is still potentially up for debate right
the fact that there's no evidence of it
at the moment does not necessarily mean
that they're not there it just means
that they haven't found additional
evidence it's incredibly difficult to
ensure that he's not there Alex what do
you make of that contradiction that they
believe it state-sponsored but there's
no evidence of a state-sponsored
attacker in the network well I actually
very much agree with with the other
guests at this point you know to say
that it is state-sponsored or not you
know everyone says that they were
compromised by a state-sponsored
attacker or an advanced persistent
threat and I think honestly I mean yahoo
obviously knows more than we do at this
point but it's a very common thing to
claim to try to absolve yourself of some
responsibility further I absolutely
agree that you know I would go a step
further and say that that network is
probably act still actively compromised
because of the breadth of business that
Yahoo does their attack surface is
essentially infinite and it is going to
be impossible to ensure anybody that
whoever compromises their net
work is completely out now a Russian
hacker reportedly started discussing the
fact that there was information this
person said was from yahoo on the
interweb somewhere Michael does that
lead you to believe that it could be
Russia behind this if indeed it is
state-sponsored you know I would
hesitate to say that it's Russia
necessarily i would say that Russia in
the past and China in the past have been
known to be actors in such
state-sponsored attacks and so that's
definitely a possibility right Russia
and China both have immense cyber
warfare capabilities it's definitely a
possibility that they could be involved
I think to Alex's point also
incidentally one thing i want to add is
when you're operating the scale of yahoo
you i think he has a great point they
have such immense surface area that even
yahoo itself is not necessarily aware of
every single server or every single
application that they support or that
they have up which isn't which is in and
of itself a problem right you need to
track down first where the attacker came
in then where they went and then where
they left and where they might still be
and if you don't know where all of your
applications and servers are that that
makes that doubly hard so Alex you know
you mentioned that this could be some
sort of excuse do you believe that there
may have been some sort of negligence
involved or that this could happen to
any company especially a company as big
as Yahoo well I think it can happen to
any company and I mean there is a
certain amount of truth that you can't
really defend yourself from someone like
Russia or China as an example in 2010
Google succumbed to operation Aurora
which was the Chinese sponsored attack
so I know wouldn't go so far as to say
that there is necessarily negligence
involves because this is almost an
intractable problem because China and
Russia can outspend whatever your
defense budget is by orders of magnitude
and eventually they're just going to win
so I think it's unfortunate that yahoo
has gotten hit this way twice in the
last few years I also think the timing
of this is rather suspicious we've seen
hacks that correspond to big financial
transactions or come out before big
financial transactions before is an
attempt to game the market
so I think this is a it's really good
food for thought to see why is this
coming out now especially considering
the verizon deal that's on the table